[Musique]
françois 1er roi de france tel qu'en lui
même
cavalier émérite séducteur impénitent
friands de chasse et de ripailles chef
de guerre aussi et stratège inspiré le
roi de la renaissance est évoquée en
plusieurs tableaux au château de
chambord
on a essayé de cerner pour tous les
goûts que ce soit et rigolo pour les
enfants et culturelles pour les adultes
et en même temps que y ait de la
prouesse physique et technique tout en
restant en sécurité parce que c'est une
saison de six mois qui est assez longue
et assez assez intense et pour les
chevaux et pour les cavaliers
inspiré de faits réels qui ont jalonné
le règne de françois 1er
le spectacle équestre est aussi un jeu
de comédiens qui met le comique au
tragique
[Musique]
dernière difficulté pas des moindres
mais les sur la même scène des chevaux
et des rapaces sans effrayer ni les uns
ni les autres
tout le mérite revient aux dresseurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
celle des oiseaux qui ont incrit fort
parce qu'il vit dans les grands espaces
et puis pour se retrouver entre eux ils
ont besoin d'un clic qui portent assez
loin
montana à quel âge à lattes avant le
spectacle équestre avec des rapaces ces
deux représentations par jour au château
de chambord jusqu'au 30 septembre
[Applaudissements]